الجزائر حيث توفي سبعة عشر شخصا
في ثلاث ولايات جزائرية نتيجة
فرنسا لبلدهم لكنه يأمل ان
يستقبل نظيره عبدالمجيد تبون في
هدوء. داعية الولايات المتحدة ما
سمته النظر للعلاقات بين البلدين
الاجتماع. نتفق على ان الصين هي
اكبر تحد استراتيجي مشترك نواجهه
الشهر الماضي من خطة طموح لتطوير
قدراتها العسكرية. ليقول وزير
الولايات المتحدة واليابان تعلن
تعزيز التعاون الامني في مواجهة
الانساني اول خطوة لتحقيق السلام
في اليمن. الاستراتيجية منطقة
للتحقيق في الوثائق المسربة
للرئيس بايدن. رئيس النظام
مكتبه في واشنطن. ووزير العدل
الامريكي يعين مستشارا خاصا
بلسانك فافعالك تقول عكس ذلك. من
جانب اخر ظهر القاتل الصامت في
اللاجئون الاوكرانيون ولا سيما
النساء في اماكن العمل في
لا يحسد على وكان اردوجان قد قال
ان تركيا تدعم فتح ممر انساني في
الاحفوري الروسي وروسيا حاولت
ابتزازنا ولكنها فشلت بسبب
يمكن ان يحصل هو ان يقول نحن
اعتذر وكل منهم يذهب في سبيله
مانويل ماكرون ويقول انه لن يطلب
الصفحة من الجزائريين عن استعمار
الاستراتيجية وغازها يسيل لعاب
الفرنسيين. لكن الكبر والغرور
الا يضر بطرف ثالث. الجزائر
ونظرة للمستقبل. قوة الجزائر
السوري بشار الاسد يضع شروطه
لتطبيع العلاقات مع تركيا قائلا
اوكرانية اخرى تعلن قوات روسيا
ابتلاعها لتقترب من السيطرة على
يجب انهاء احتلال انقرة لاجزاء
من سوريا ووقف دعم الارهاب.
وفي مراب سياراته في ويلمنتون
بولاية ديلاوير بعد تلك التي في
والتقدم في ظل قصف مدفعي محتمل.
تمت محاكاته بمتفجرات حقيقية.
هذه المرة. وبعد اخبار اقتراب
مشاركة بلاروسيا في الحرب
يستوجب الرد ومن رقعة الحروب
والمعارك الى طاولة المفاوضات.
بلاروسيا. وتدربت القوات على
التكتيكات القتالية واطلاق النار
الجانبين اتفقا ايضا على تمديد
شروط معاهدة الدفاع المشترك
بموضوعية وعقلانية مضيفة ان
التعاون بين واشنطن وطوكيو يجب
الحوثيون يطالبون الوفد العماني
بتحمل مسؤولية الاهتمام بالملف
احادي اكسيد الكربون المنبعث من
مختلف تجهيزات التدفئة الاختناق
تدور وها انت تدور حول نفسك
طالبا الصفحة وان انكرت ذلك
ما افادت وكالة الانباء
الجزائرية الرسمية. ويسبب غاز
استنشاق غاز عديم اللون والرائحة
خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة فقط. حسب
لكن الجزائريين لن ينسوا اكثر من
مليون شهيد يا هذا وها هي الايام
للمواطنين. الاحداث والتطورات.
وثائق سرية جديدة في منزل بايدن
بين البلدين. ليحاول ماكرون
تبرير كلامه بقوله ان اسوأ ما
اسرائيل. تنتهي حياة العديد منهن
بالانتحار وفقا لموقع زمان
تلك القضية. ومن معارك المفاوضات
الى حرب الاستغلال. فهناك سلسلة
السرب الثالث من انظمة صواريخ اس
اربعمائة ريوف الروسية الى الهند
باريس هذا العام لمواصلة العمل
معا على ملف الذاكرة والمصالحة
لتشمل الفضاء ايضا. بينما ردت
الصين على هذه التحالفات بكل
بحري مع اليابان والذي سيوفر
قدرات كبيرة منها الصواريخ
تمتلك انقرة ردا ان اردوغان
سيتصل ببوتين والزينسكي لمناقشة
مشافيها لتظهر مفوضة حقوق
الانسان في روسيا مطالبة انقرة
نحن وحلفاؤنا وشركاؤنا. كما اعلن
وزير الدفاع الامريكي عن تعاون
طاحنة هناك وان جبهة صامدة على
حد قوله. موسكو لا تتوقف. ووزارة
يجعل مضغ هذه الحقيقة صعبا على
باريس ليخرج الرئيس الفرنسي
المضادة للسفن لتنتقل المواجهة
للفضاء حيث قال بلينكن ان
الخارجية الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
في مؤتمر صحفي مشترك بعد
دفاعها تعلن تعيين قائدا
للمجموعة المشتركة للقوات في
في سوليدر ما زال مستمرا ومشيرا
الى ان قوات بلاده تخوض معارك
الاوكرانيسكي للسلام. لتستمر حرب
المفاوضات الروسية. لكن البوصلة
المخاوف المشتركة تجاه الصين
لتؤيد واشنطن ما اعلنته طوكيو
جارية حاليا ليشتعل غضب
الامريكان فهل من رد امريكي على
وحدتنا. وفي سياق اخر كشفت صحيفة
التايمز اوف انديا عن ان تسليم
الخصوم على جمع التحالفات
لمواجهة التنين الصيني. فها هما
رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية ان
اسعار الغاز ادنى مما كانت عليه
قبل الهجوم الروسي بفضل جهودهم
وقالت كنا نعتمد على الوقود
هذه الصفقة? الصين تربك اعدائها.
تسارع قوات الصين المذهل اجبر
فهل تعتبر مينسك تيف المناورات
تحذيرا اوكرانيا ام انه استفزاز
منطقة العملية الخاصة. والكرملين
يقول ان توسيع نطاق العملية
بتوضيح فوري حول مقصد رئيسها
بانشاء ممر انساني بين روسيا
حقا الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديمرزيلنسكي مؤكدا ان القتال
كبدت قوات كييف خسائر فادحة تفوق
اكثر من سبعمائة قتيل خلال ثلاثة
واوكرانيا دون استشارة الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حينها لم
اوكرانيا وان بلاده على استعداد
لمعالجة الجرحى العسكريين في
العسكرية هو سبب تعيين القائد
الجديد. رد كييف لم يكن ضد موسكو
توجهت اليوم نحو تركيا يوضع
الرئيس التركي اردوغان في موقف
حيث جددت وزارة الخارجية الروسية
رفض موسكو خطة الرئيس
اسرائيل. ننتقل الى حرب الغاز
بين الاوروبيين وروسيا حيث اعلنت
الاوكرانية اجرت قوات كييف
مناورات عسكرية بالقرب من حدود
من الفظائع والاغتصابات وسوء
المعاملة والاستغلال يعانيها
الحقت خسائر كبيرة باللواء واحد
وستين الاوكراني خارج مدينة
تفجرها وزارة الدفاع الروسية
للعلن. نعم. لقد تم الانتهاء من
سوليدار مقدرة الخسائر البشرية
بثلاثمائة قتيل اوكراني. بينما
ايام. انها معارك تكسير العظام
يا سادة. بل انتهت معارك سوليدار
الوزارة ان ذلك سيسهل لقواتها
التحرك نحو باخموت القريبة
لاستمرار العمليات الهجومية
الناجحة على محور دونيدسك. واضاف
اعتذر وما كان يخفيه بايدن ظهر
اليوم للعلن ومن اجل التصالح.
كعكة موسكو الجديدة. الموت
يتساقط من كل مكان. البيوت مدمرة
والمدينة اصبحت اطلالا لم يبقى
فيها شيء غير بضعة مجموعات
والاكبر من سوليدار بكثير. وقالت
الدفاع الروسية ايضا ان قواتها
تحرير مدينة سوليدار بالكامل
مؤكدة ان هذا الامر يعد مهما
مدينة سوليدار. حيث اعلنت وسائل
اعلام روسية ان مدفعية موسكو
المبادرة وتعلن الحاق خسائر
كبيرة بالقوات الاوكرانية قرب
عسكرية يتمركزون في هذا الطرف او
ذاك. لتأخذ روسيا بدورها
اسرائيل تستغل الاوكرانيين
بطريقة سيئة بينما الهند تترك
القاتل الصامت في تزايد مستمر
والرئيس الفرنسي للجزائريين. لن
سترد واشنطن؟ بينما هنا تحالف
معلن بين امريكا واليابان
السلاح الامريكي وتذهب نحو سلاح
روسي. فهل هناك جديد اذا وكيف
لمواجهة الصين وبكين ترفع كارتها
الاحمر. وفي الجزائر ضحايا
سوريا تضع شروطا تعجيزية لتركيا.
اوكرانيا وارقام فلكية في اعداد
القتلى اوروبا تعلن عن مفاجأة
لروسيا بشأن اسعار الغاز وموسكو
تضع اردوجان في موقف محرج.
حرب اوكرانية بطعم الموت. روسيا
تسيطر على احدى اكبر مدن
باخموت باكملها. فماذا بعد ذلك
ايها الروس?